stell dir vor du bist zu hause fuchs
gerade ganz entspannt youtube-videos und
plötzlich stürmt die polizei dein haus
sie kommen in dein zimmer und nehmen
sich fest weil du morgen ein verbrechen
begangen hättest im film minority report
passiert genau das
dort bekommt tom cruise seine
informationen von drei mutierten
menschen die ihnen die zukunft gucken
können aber in der realität passiert
heute schon etwas ganz ähnliches
und zwar mit hilfe von künstlicher
intelligenz in der englischen grafschaft
kent verwendet die polizei einen
algorithmus der vorhersagen über
mögliche verbrechen macht basierend auf
daten der vergangenheit bekommen die
polizisten zum beispiel angezeigt in
welchem stadtviertel heute besonders
hohe kriminelle aktivität zu erwarten
ist
so können die beamten gezielt auf
streife gehen das problem dabei noch hat
niemand in diesem viertel ein verbrechen
begangen
ein computerprogramm stellt einen ganzen
gruppe von menschen unter
generalverdacht
ist das nun gut weil es uns hilft
kriminalität vorzubeugen oder schlecht
weil es unsere freiheit einschränkt und
womöglich menschengruppen unterdrückt
werden
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
auf dr
[Musik]
dieses jahr findet das wissenschaftsjahr
2009 10 künstliche intelligenz vom
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung statt
anlässlich dazu werde ich eine reihe von
videos zum thema künstlicher intelligenz
produzieren
aber was ist künstliche intelligenz
eigentlich genau
wenn ihr erst mal verstehen wollte was
ein neuronales netz macht und wie eine
maschine lernen kann dann schaut euch am
besten einmal dieses video von mir an
die kurzfassung davon ist aber dass du
ein algorithmus nur eine große
mathematische formel ist die versucht
etwas zu optimieren
und dafür braucht diese formel daten
eine menge daten big data ist ein
begriff den viele inzwischen gehört
haben er bezeichnet eine menge an daten
die so groß ist dass man sie nicht mehr
auf herkömmliche weise bearbeiten kann
ich deswegen werden algorithmen
eingesetzt um diese riesige datenmenge
zu durchwühlen und daraus schlau zu
werden
solche datenmengen können unfalldaten
von versicherern patientendaten mit
einer bestimmten krankheit oder guckte
youtube-videos sein und genau so
unterschiedlich können die ziele
dahinter sein
während youtube möchte dass du besonders
viele youtube videos guckst und den
algorithmus entsprechend darauf
trainiert versucht die versicherung den
richtigen preis für ihr produkt zu
finden
aber der große vorteil dieser
flexibilität ist genauso eine
schwachstelle
denn der algorithmus hat keine moral
vorstellung kein bewusstsein das einzige
was erkennt sind die daten mit denen er
gefüttert wurde
und die sind nicht immer neutral die
software zur bekämpfung von kriminalität
zum beispiel basiert logischerweise nur
auf vorfällen die der polizei bekannt
sind
gegenüber vergehen die nicht auffallen
verbrechen die nicht gemeldet wurden
oder vorfällen die als unfall
gekennzeichnet wurden ist der
algorithmus blind wenn man länger
darüber nachdenkt merkt man dass diese
software also vor allem den leuten hilft
denen sowieso schon geholfen wird und
sich gegen die menschen richtet die
sowieso im fadenkreuz der polizei sind
der algorithmus verstärkt die bereits
vorhandene situation
das wird algorithmics bayers also etwa
algorithmische verzerrung genannt und
kann schlimme folgen haben
einer kann software in den usa wurde zum
beispiel vor kurzem vorgeworfen
rassistisch zu sein die software
bewertet die chance dass kriminelle
wieder straffällig werden
richter nutzen diesen score dann um zu
entscheiden ob sie wieder aus dem
gefängnis entlassen werden können oder
nicht
einer studie zufolge aber gibt die
software menschen mit ähnlichen
straftaten unterschiedliche scores der
einzige unterschied ist oft die
hautfarbe da statistisch gesehen
schwarze in diesem us-bundesstaat
häufiger erneut straffällig werden
fließt die es auch in den score 1
obwohl zwei männer das gleiche
verbrechen begangen haben muss einer
länger im gefängnis bleiben als der
andere das ist racial profiling in den
usa verboten und zeigt wie vorsichtig
man mit ki umgehen muss machine learning
ist eine blackbox man trainiert einen
algorithmus mit daten und hofft dass das
richtige ergebnis dabei herauskommt oft
tut es das mit genügend daten auch aber
wieder algorithmus dann funktioniert
kann keiner genau sagen
bei einem text org stellte peter haas
einen algorithmus vor der diesen husky
fälschlicherweise als wolf erkannt hat
als die forscher das programm
umgeschrieben haben um zu sehen auf
welche stellen des bildes der
algorithmus bei seiner entscheidung
achtet kann das hier heraus das
wichtigste element für den algorithmus
war der schnee im hintergrund des bildes
das liegt vermutlich daran dass viele
bilder von wölfen die dem algorithmus
zum lernen gegeben wurden im schnee
waren die daten waren verzerrt und der
algorithmus erkannte trotz seiner hohen
genauigkeit nicht wirklich wölfe sondern
vielmehr die umgebung in denen sie sich
aufhalten
das gefährliche an ki ist nicht das
horrorszenario dass wir von einer
unglaublich intelligenten maschine
unterjocht werden sondern dass ganz
normale menschen einem algorithmus
vertrauen von dem wir nicht wissen wie
er funktioniert wie können wir das
verhindern
nun der wichtigste schritt ist dass
menschen die arbeiten dieses problem
kennen und aktiv versuchen es zu
vermeiden
gleichzeitig sollten diese menschen
selber divers aufgestellt sein und von
möglichst vielen verschiedenen
hintergründen kommen hier diverser die
schöpfer sind desto universeller ist
auch der algorithmus
das setzt natürlich voraus dass diese
schöpfer überhaupt gutes im sinn haben
die chinesische regierung baut gerade
das größte überwachungssystem aller
zeiten auf zu großen teilen mit
künstlicher intelligenz die regierung
überwacht jeden winkel der
öffentlichkeit kein bürger per
gesichtserkennung identifizieren und
verfolgen
genutzt wird das um alle zu besseren
verhalten anzuregen menschen die zum
beispiel quer über die straße laufen
werden erkannt und bekommen direkt nach
ihrer straftat eine sms mit der bitte
dies doch in zukunft bleiben zu lassen
wird derjenige erneut auffällig so
werden ihm punkte von seinem sozial
kreditkonto abgezogen
dieses konto zeigt an wie gut sich
jemand an die regeln der regierung hält
wie gehorsam jemand ist kg ist ein
werkzeug um gibt demjenigen macht der
weiß wie man es verwendet da es aber
große mengen an daten und computer power
braucht um einen algorithmus zu
trainieren
droht die gefahr dass nur wohlhabende
und mächtige gruppen dieses werkzeug
nutzen können sie könnte dafür sorgen
dass reichen noch reicher werden und
machthaber ihre macht weiter ausbauen
können sie sollte aber allen menschen
zugleich der umwelt und den tieren
dienen
künstliche intelligenz dringt in immer
mehr bereiche unseres lebens ein
geht dieses werkzeug also gerade nach
hinten los und sorgt dafür dass es
menschen insgesamt schlechter geht
nein er hat bereits vielen menschen
geholfen und es gab in letzter zeit ein
paar geniale durchbrüche die ohne diese
technologie gar nicht möglich gewesen
wäre
aber wir müssen darauf aufpassen dass
wir richtig mit diesem werkzeug umgehen
dass es nicht in die falschen hände
gerät oder wir unabsichtlich leuten
schaden da wir nicht wissen wie diese
große matheformeln denkt können wir den
ergebnissen nicht blind vertrauen
am ende des tages muss immer ein mensch
überwachen was ein algorithmus
entschieden hat was sind eure gedanken
zu diesem extrem kontroversen thema
begrüßt in diese neuen möglichkeiten
oder seid ihr eher skeptisch gegenüber
ki eingestellt ich lese wie immer alle
kommentare hier unten und das video
schreibt ich bin schon sehr gespannt auf
eure meinungen und diskutiere gerne mit
euch
vielen dank an die gemeinnützige
organisation wissenschaft im dialog und
das bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung für die unterstützung bei
diesem video
wie gesagt es wird noch einige weitere
videos zum thema geben also abonniert
main kanal um nichts zu verpassen
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]